he is the harvard professor
psychology professor whose news best
seller is enlightenment now the case for
reason science humanism and progress
stephen pinker
[Applause]
how are you sir many people face the
news
each morning with trepidation and dread
and it's very hard to predict
uh when there'll be a tipping point
although i think it's safe to say
that the the the handshake may be doomed
you can always fool yourself into seeing
a decline
if you compare leading headlines of the
present with
rose tinted images of the past it i mean
what's going on in the world today
i mentioned a little bit in the
monologue that the record heats i mean
people dying in japan and places where
they never did from heat
we're not even starting on that well we
are starting on it we're not doing
nearly enough and it is the greatest
threat
uh face facing humanity but there are uh
road maps to decarbonizing the economy
that we have to implement and accelerate
they include
both uh policy measures like a carbon
tax so that
every economic decision that everyone on
the planet makes factors in that we're
not doing it that's the
thing there is no carbon just start yeah
life is better than death health is
better than sickness
abundance is better than want freedom is
better than coercion
happiness is better than suffering and
knowledge is better than
ignorance and superstition thank you
hi everybody today's episode features
none other than
harvard university professor dr stephen
pinker
who is a phenomenal intellect he's
really one of these public intellectuals
he's a philosopher he's a psychologist
he is a
a rational thinker he is a humanist and
we got into all sorts of topics and more
in today's episode i think you're really
going to enjoy it i hope that if you do
you'll
uh you'll leave a rating a review and
let me know what you think about these
podcasts wherever you're watching or
listening to them
please subscribe to my newsletter at
briankeating.com
most of my guests subscribe there and uh
i get to keep in touch with them and
and who knows you couldn't find a better
company to be
within than the into the impossible
audience i really thank you all so much
in this time we're still coming to the
end of the pandemic but the pandemic
podcasting will remain
and continue because there's no reason
to stop a good thing
i'm having so much fun i hope you are
too uh send me suggestions leave
comments or wherever you can
and uh subscribe to my newsletter and
send me an email
briankating.com anyway enjoy today's
episode steven is a brilliant person
he's
fun to talk to made plenty of time he's
a new book coming out in
uh in the fall stay tuned for that i'm
going to have him back and maybe a
giveaway of his books
so please enjoy this episode
with professor steven finker
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
today we are joined on the into the
impossible podcast by professor stephen
pinker the john stone family professor
in the department of psychology
at harvard university he's the author of
many books
including the language instinct how the
mind works the blank slate the stuff of
thought the better angels of our nature
the sense of style which i i do love
that book and
enlightenment now which is most recently
and actually
uh stephen you were uh you you actually
preempted what i was going to
open our conversation with by your
forthcoming book rationality because i
actually got
re-exposed to you during the pandemic uh
courtesy of our mutual friend michael
shermer who tweeted out how about a free
harvard education and rationality this
is in spring of 2020
uh watch steven pinker's uh cog
general education class on rationality
and i started to watch it i watched all
the lectures including the guest
lectures and it was amusing kind of
frozen in amber
this transition from in-person lectures
to covid
you know remote lectures only but i was
going to write you stephen you don't
know who i am
but uh but i have a good idea for you
why don't you take your
all your lectures and turn it into a
book but i
feel like you already had the idea so uh
can you mention briefly what the nature
of russia
yeah you're right we violate time and
space
and i i took your advice my next book is
called rationality
what it is why it seems scarce why it
matters
well that's funny because uh supposedly
one once uh about a decade ago stephen
hawking
set up a table in uh in the
university of cambridge university and
it said welcome time travelers from the
future
and people like what is he doing and
then the next day he the next day he
advertised it
and the joke was you know they would
only be attend this event
if they could actually travel back into
so that's the origin of steven's book
we're actually uh violating time and
space
but i want to start off by talking about
rationality and i want to get your
prescription as a doctor as am i uh of
philosophy in a sense about rationality
so today on my way to campus
i walked by some students and they were
skateboarding whizzing down the street
on the sidewalks or whatever and they
were on their cell phone or
you know typing on their cell phone on
their skateboard not wearing a helmet
steven
but wearing a mask so they were afraid
you know
nervous about covid uh but not wearing a
helmet and
uh and going at breakneck speed what do
you make of you know these are some of
the brightest
you know students and humans in the on
the planet uh and i assume similar
phenomena can be witnessed at harvard
what do you make of
even educated people being so bad at
making rational decisions
yes well rationality is always a means
to an end
we don't call someone rational if they
just
prove arbitrary theorems or spit out the
digits of pi you've got to have a goal
and often the goal is one that we may
not agree with or that may itself not be
rational by held to certain criteria
so uh the wearing of masks as we know
has become
a decision that people make not only for
the
benefit toward themselves protecting
themselves against
catching a contagious disease or
protection against
others not spreading it in case you do
have it but it's also become a symbol
it's become a means of uh
of advertising what coalition
you are sympathetic with and so uh
bizarrely enough it became a symbol on
the american right
of uh defiance of the left defiance of
government and even on the left there
are
conditions in which there really is not
a whole lot of benefit to wearing a mask
like you're
by yourself on a beach and some people
wear it there
to signal where their heart lies
in terms of whether or not you wear a
helmet there is
a trade-off of course between the
feeling of the wind through your hair
and you know looking really cool and
increasing the chances that you will not
die in a in a fatal accident
and there isn't you know an objectively
correct answer to the question
which is the more rational of those
goals to pursue
i think if we thought thought it through
deeply enough we would probably come to
agree that that
few moments of pleasure and vanity don't
outweigh
the chance however small of dying in an
accident but
um those personal choices always involve
tradeoffs between competing values
and i've heard it said even there was a
study in the proceedings of the national
academy of sciences
which you know i've taken to saying
lately what they used to say about the
journal nature
they used to say just because it's in
nature doesn't necessarily mean it's
wrong
um but actually we're finding a lot of
things nowadays
published in the new york post and these
are like hardcores you know science
papers
are at least that the theories behind
them are you know pretty severe uh
significant like avi loeb
had some some pieces published in in the
new york post or
op-eds about his discoveries uh related
to omua
i want to talk about that because
actually it seems that sometimes
the most polarized people in society and
even those that have the most polarized
views about
science and scientific things like
global warming or
our stem cell research etc they actually
can be correlated with people with high
scientific degrees of education
and i wonder is that a byproduct of kind
of you know the
not the dunning-kruger effect which as i
understand you are of course much more
astute about it than i am but it's sort
of like you know this phrase that
you know something so preposterous that
only an intellectual could believe it
i do see things nowadays where people
you know are so entrenched
scientifically
and they they believe that their
scientific credentials extend
you know to other disciplines and so we
hear about people um
you know that that won the nobel prize
in condensed matter physics and they'll
opine about the
uh an iran treaty so what is it about
even rational people like i know that
that this person is not an expert
in iran policy and nuclear uh
you know the denuclearization but why do
we feel this need to
to kind of get authority from people
that you know
may not have the earn the discipline you
know the prestige that we're ascribing
to them
why are academics in particular so quick
to ascribe
you know this this bias in favor of
things said by their fellow academicians
shall we say
yes well it's part of the uh inherent
problem of knowing anything that that we
have to
take advantage of the division of labor
because you know none of us knows
everything most of us know
at best a little bit about something
which means that we have to
in some sense trust those who know more
about the subject matter than we do
which in turn raises the question of who
and on what basis
should we trust someone because truth be
told
i don't understand enough about
atmospheric chemistry
to work out for myself that human-made
climate change is a fact and a lot of
the people who
do uh believe what you and i would
probably
say is the the correct belief namely
that human activity is warming the
planet
a lot of them are completely out to
lunch as to why if you ask them
what's the cause of global warming they
might say oh toxic waste dumps or
the ozone hole have this vague sense of
something
of pollution and green is good and
pollution is bad
nonetheless by taking seriously the
people who really
do understand the problem they do arrive
at the
uh what we would uh agree is the the the
uh
the best supported opinion so the
question is on what basis
should you trust others now credentials
are a kind of shortcut they're kind of
uh heuristic
that uh is are a better guide
to whom to trust than uh
the guy at the end of the bar or
something that you read on twitter
on the other hand it's only as good as
the actual
basis for for the the credential
and as you point out if you earn a
phd in a particular subject if you get
hired by a department if you publish in
those journals that doesn't
automatically entitle you to expertise
in
other subjects and there is a long list
of
nobel prize winners in science who have
endorsed
crackpot theories including esp and
homeopathy
and crank autism cures and denial of
anthropogenic climate change and
so on eugenics yeah
and you can't even go by um
whether they the uh
sheepskin on the wall is for that
particular discipline
because even experts can
fall out of the consensus of their own
field or father gotta consent
away from the consensus is itself no
indicator necessarily
being wrong but they can pursue their
own conceits
conversely people who
take the time to learn about the best
research in some other field
might have a perfect right to express
their
opinions on it if they can back it up
with
research in the field that they're
talking about if they have good
reasoning
if they base their factual claims
on documented uh findings
so there's no formula for who to trust
but uh one has to follow the train of
evidence did that person
does that person have good grounds for
what they
are claiming does it stand up to logic
is it supported by facts
yeah i always say when i'm asked as i'm
often uh done and i assume it happens to
you as well
you know at a talk i'll give about
cosmology someone say what do you think
about global warming
and i'll say i hope when you have an
atmospheric chemist you know from
scripps institute of
oceanography here when you have her come
and speak and you ask her about
cosmology
she doesn't answer the question you know
she says well you should talk to a
cosmologist
and just the same way yeah so a little
knowledge is a dangerous thing as as
your late great colleague stephen j
gould
was the author of the leader of the
series on
uh scientific uh these treatise of
scientific classics
of which galileo's dialogue is one and
in this book
translated by stillman drake and it's a
classic edition forward by some guy
named albert einstein
uh in it i know that galileo says these
wonderful things that i think
i want to run it by you because i think
i'll get i will get a kick and maybe my
audience will too
but um what what does this sound like to
you this is galileo who is a wonderful
writer
incredibly brilliant orator and and
writer not so great politically
shall we say but he said um he said the
following for
anyone this vain presumption of
understanding everything can have
no other basis than never understanding
anything
for anyone who had experienced just once
the perfect understanding of one single
thing
and had tasted how knowledge is truly
accomplished he would recognize that of
the infinity of other truths
he understands nothing and i think
i think of this as like the
dunning-kruger effect like galileo
writing in 1632
anticipating this kind of effect that
later i i believe that uh richard
feynman nobel laureate said
he said science is the belief in the
ignorance of experts
not the wisdom of experts in that if
science would stagnate if we all of a
sudden just said okay well you know
newton was right he was a genius and i i
don't have to investigate these
departures of the planet mercury
i don't have to worry about that um what
do you say about the fact there's
always this tension stephen between the
respecting of the
of the past the received wisdom if you
will as a scientist but always
having to assume that they're wrong and
um and it's
sort of this dichotomy that is because
there's a danger of saying well you
scientists don't know anything you
you said 30 years ago manhattan would be
underwater but no
no you should listen to us now and 30
years from now it'll be under water
but the reasoning is you know it's not
like the laws of chemistry or physics
have changed
how do you convince someone that the
scientific method is
provisional it is subject to consensus
but it should be the best tool that we
have as human beings to make sense of
our world
well that that absolutely is the the
crux of the
uh issue of what ought a rational person
to believe
um negotiating the trade-off between
having to trust in people who know more
about it than you do
but not trusting them because of their
credentials because of their
uh fancy schmancy position because of
their authoritative tone of voice
but rather because they have done the
the uh
the relevant work they can cite the
relevant
facts uh and it is crucial as you point
out that to to note that we
all start out ignorant of everything and
in fact if
if a scientist gets something wrong that
should not impugn the credibility of the
enterprise but strengthen it namely
since no one is omniscient no one has
been vouchsafed with the truth god has
not implanted
correct beliefs in any of us our only
option
is to frame explanations of phenomena
and to
let the world tell us whether they're
right or wrong and so in the early days
of the pandemic for example
when you when opinion did change because
it was a new pathogen there was a
new mode of transmission no one really
understood anything
and some of the advice did flip-flop and
the wrong conclusion would be
well that just shows you shouldn't trust
scientists because they say one thing
one week
and another thing the other week it
should be well yes we should trust
at least the methods of science not
necessarily any given scientist
because given that we start out ignorant
it is our best means
of reducing our ignorance right yeah and
and similar i think on the on the you
know radical or you know self-declared
you know humanistics or
or maybe even militant militant
self-declared atheists like lawrence
krauss or richard dawkins
you know there is this tendency well if
you don't like it if you don't believe
in science
then you shouldn't use a cell phone
because a cell phone uses general
relativity to make corrections to the
time delay yeah
i think that's a little overblown as
well like i don't think we have to
you know accept the issue of you know
it's like what scientist
another thing that galileo said is you
know uh you know what a thousand
you know scientists are not worth the
humble reasoning of a single individual
so
it is true although i get a lot of
emails like people thought einstein was
wrong people think i'm wrong
therefore i'm einstein you know will you
help me you know win a nobel prize and
i'll share the money with you
uh but but nevertheless i do feel like
there we live in this age where as carl
sagan said
you know never has so much technology
been present by people that understand
it so poorly
and i feel like it's getting worse like
moore's law and everything else and the
progress of inevitable
you know progression of human technology
and science that you and i are part of
um is only going to make that problem
worse so we're only going to understand
technology
less and less relative to what is um and
what is available
so are you us still optimistic you know
is the is a trajectory that
you outline so beautifully and
enlightened and then now
you know do we feel after witnessing a
pandemic and all the kind of
irrationality that was surrounding it
are you more optimistic less optimistic
sort of the same
well the people often characterize
enlightenment now
and the book that i wrote two books
previously the better angels of our
nature
as briefs for optimism but that really
is not not what they are
right uh they're not encouraging people
to take a particular mindset to
wear rose-colored glasses see the
glasses half-full look on the bright
side
they're trying to make people aware of
facts that they're ignorant of
most people if you ask them have wars
gotten
better or worse over the last 50 years
they'll say they'll say worse
you ask them has global poverty
extreme poverty gotten better or worse
they'll they'll say it's gotten worse
and you know they're wrong and they're
wrong poverty has been
extreme poverty has been decimated
literacy has increased longevity has
increased
rates of death in war and genocide have
plunged
now people just are incorrect in their
beliefs about these phenomena
and uh because if you base your
understanding of the world
on events in the media you're getting a
highly distorted view of the world
because
journalism is a non-random sample of the
worst events that have happened on a
given day
right and all of the things that don't
happen like a country
that is not at war or things that happen
gradually
like 137 000 people escaping from
extreme poverty
every single day just aren't headlines
they happen
they build up they change the world and
no one's aware of them
so that's really the was the point of
both of those books
rather than well let's assume that
everything will get better because
things don't get better by themselves
they get better
only because and you know as a as a
physicist you'd be the first to uh
acknowledge that the laws of the
universe don't care about us uh
if anything they seem to grind us down
they uh there's the second law of
thermodynamics
uh in when it comes to uh our
position in the natural world as
organisms
we are vulnerable to pathogens and
parasites like all living things
you and i are big juicy hunks of meat
there for the eating by you know
itty-bitty organisms that can evolve a
lot faster than we can because their
generation time is in minutes rather
than in in decades uh
and so we're sitting ducks for for
pathogens and germs we have to
the only reason we're not all dead is
that uh we've uh fought back
in uh our evolutionary history we fought
back with
our immune system we fought back with
sexual reproduction so our kids aren't
clones of ourselves and our
germs have to start all over again
evolving to crack their
molecular defenses we have primitive
behavioral emotions like
disgust and xenophobia
but what we've developed in the last
couple of centuries
is the application of reason to fight
back against
little little germs such as vaccinations
such as antibiotics
such as sanitation such as public health
measures
and it's only by applying our ingenuity
deployed toward the goal of keeping
people alive and healthy and happy
that we can push back against all these
forces of the cosmos that are trying to
uh to grind us down or at best i mean
now that's a little bit too
anthropomorphic they're not really
trying they just don't care
and things left to their own devices
things get worse
yeah there's the teleological kind of
overlay that's almost impossible and
what i do
and and uh to some extent with my
colleagues in in evolutionary biology
etc do uh you mentioned the media and i
thought you know i made this observation
you know recently on online somewhere
you know that never has it been the case
where media
were never not guided by a profit motive
in other words we're living in an
extraordinary time where
you know billionaires control huge media
empires from elect
pure electronic to print media um
and and and and hybrid models as well
and uh and that can be shut off at a
moment's notice
access can be denied at a moment's
notice there's no appeals board there's
no
and there's no government court it's not
it's not governmental so you can't claim
freedom of speech issues or or denial of
rights
but it's still a phenomenal experience
in the sense that
never has it been that a newspaper was
completely free of any concern of making
a profit and i wonder
is that contributing to some of the
radical kind of polarization that we're
seeing or do you feel like it's
unprecedented or permanent or do you
think that
that's going to change and people will
vote for their pocketbooks
i see that less happening less less and
less often nowadays
yeah it's certainly not unprecedented in
that as you as you note
the uh organs of journalism have always
been
for-profit uh organizations and that's
in some ways it's a good thing if the
alternative is pravda or azvestia where
they're
government-owned um although bbc doesn't
do too badly although it has its own
biases as well
uh but it has competition which is a
good thing uh
the you know what we can count on
because even though it is true
that they uh their ultimate motive is to
uh to make a profit and one of the ways
of making a profit in the current
climate is to appeal to
a rabbit constituency that just the
economics are not
that you aim at the center and try to
expand at the
um at the fringes but rather you find
your constituency and you feed them
red meat so that is part of the problem
one hopes that journalists and
this is true of most of the journalists
that i've spoken to they
at least that the people doing the
writing feel that they're
serving a higher good they are uh
altruists and that were or idealists
in the sense that they think they're you
know writing the first draft of history
preventing democracy from dying in
darkness
and that one could appeal to that part
of them that is idealistic
that isn't just chasing eyeballs and
clicks to to say
well you know stop and think twice about
what you're doing to the
marketplace of ideas to the public
sphere because it's true that i think
there's
that um there's a lot of
thoughtlessness not just in the pursuit
of profit
but in the um in prosecuting various
uh moral crusades in in seeing their
goal
as to shift the discussion in a
particular direction as opposed to
giving people
a factual basis on which to to make
these choices
right um you mentioned a couple things
there one is the marketplace of ideas
and the other is red meat
let me go to red meat first um so
looking back in history you know i've
been thinking well you know
obviously our founding fathers had
tremendous you know
flaws and they and they committed you
know what we consider now than the [ __ ]
you know the shifting moral zeitgeist
etc
uh and the moral relativism that every
age employs but i'm wondering like if
there might not be a trend to like
pregame the future you know kind of a
science fiction
type way which i know you're a fan of
science fiction um having listened to
your podcast with dave curtly on the
geeks guide to the galaxy many years ago
but um but nevertheless
looking at the future saying well in the
future probably there'll be no need for
red meat i had on chase purdy who's the
author of billion dollar burger about
stem cell grown meat lab grown meat
and it seems clear to me that this will
be very commonplace
i had an impossible burger for you know
for lunch yesterday
um in the future is it not possible that
any of us who ate red meat
i'm not saying that i did or ever have
for the future uh but
that will be looked upon the same way
that people look upon our founding
fathers for
you know the atrocity of owning slaves
it could it could very well happen
so we shifted from figurative red meat
to literal regimes literally
uh it's eminently possible in fact
we should hope that it happens that some
of the practices today
that we take for granted will be seen by
our descendants as as barbaric as we
certainly are are doing
plenty of harm it also means that
looking backward
we this has been said before that it's
it's anachronistic and indeed
uh morally obtuse to hold
our ancestors to standards that they
could not have
dreamed of at the time and therefore the
problem is going forward
is that we are apt to blame harms on
bad people as opposed to bad norms and
institutions and assumptions and beliefs
and therefore
to exculpate ourselves because of course
you know we're i'm a good person that
you're a good person all my pals are
good people
that is a way of giving yourself a pass
at customs that
may objectively be abominable but if
your
moral uh philosophy is
bad things are done by bad people and we
get to decide what's good and bad you
have to
give yourself a pass at uh at
indefensible practices
so yes it may be and
meat eating especially when it comes
from factory farms might be
a practice that our descendants look
back on the way we look back on
slave auctions and heretic burnings and
public hangings and
laughing at the insane and keeping
harems and so on
and then there may be others our our
regime of uh criminal punishment
our drug laws our possession of nuclear
weapons
all these in a particular frame of mind
might be seen as
um as both insane and evil
but uh they're the only way we know how
to do things now and so we might accept
them too quickly if we just think oh
well we're all
uh good and decent people you've given
me another
business idea thank you steve for um a
job of future
moral consultants so what practices do i
have to stop now
in order not to be looked down upon 100
years hence and
i'm going to be consulting with my
friends who do have harems to this very
day
thank you for that steve the problem is
well the problem is it's so much
it's really easy to do it about our
ancestors it's not exactly do it but
ourselves yes
and i want to take the flip side of that
coin so in science we talk as you know
isaac newton once said you know we stand
on the shoulders of giants although some
say he was saying it as a
as an insult a pejorative one of his
colleagues maybe leibniz was
very short and he was making fun of him
or something uh but you know the other
one is looking over the shoulder of
short people
but but nevertheless we have this
reverence okay we know aristotle
believed there were four elements
okay now there's you know 114 on the
table to my
to my left over here on the wall um we
know that he thought that
you know the earth was the center of the
universe okay but he also came up with
the laws of you know modus
ponens and he came up with the laws of
logic he was the first to discover as i
point out it's very relevant to me
and where you are on the cape you know
he discovered that whales were mammals
i think that's very important to my
daily life i'm sure are yours too
but but um but we acknowledge he made
mistake but he made these incredible
contributions to our understanding of
the natural world and the processes by
which we comprise
of the world around us we come in in a
spinning globe we have no no
but why is it that you know the same
kind of courtesy
reverence forbearance if you will is not
extended to
in the in the moral sphere to religion
in other words
we we sometimes act as if well the world
starts spinning and
now we're the ones that can judge the
people that ate meat in the 2020s
you know something like that but but
who's to say that you know these people
weren't the equivalents in the religion
which carried a lot of moral
um thinking through um as well as the
enlightenment obviously
but um but who's to say that they're not
giants as well in other words it seems
like they're looked down upon
at least in the in the realm of you know
pre-enlightenment versus
in science we don't look down on galileo
because he didn't come up with the
lorenz contraction so
to what extent do do we too harshly
judge the moral
you know standards of religious
practitioners you know
a few hundred years ago and even to this
day well it's uh
it depends who you're who you're
targeting
there are uh people like uh like my
friends richard dawkins and uh
the late christopher hitchens and uh
dan dennett who point out that the
bible is a pretty awful guide to
morality
because the overwhelming opinion in our
culture
is that the bible is the source of our
moral values
even someone is distinguished to stephen
j gould who we brought up a few minutes
ago
in his book rocks of ages in making the
valid point that science itself
can't uh uh on its own be a source of
morality says well that's what religion
is for
but and that is you know he was not a
theologian he was not a philosopher
but he was conveying a widespread view
that when it comes to right and wrong we
should
look to the bible our elected officials
put their hands on the bible when
there's
they're uh sworn in uh so the the people
who
note the some of the atrocities that
were sanctioned in the bible are very
much a minority
now you're right if they tried to cancel
the bible and said we should burn the
bible and no one should ever read it
and religion should be shut down because
they because the bible
sanctioned uh genocide and slavery and
rape
now that would be historically obtuse uh
there are some good things in the in in
the bible and the ten commandments
but you know thou shalt not cover thy
covet by neighbors
livestock at the same time as it gave a
pass to
you know rape and slavery means that we
shouldn't take it
literally as the source of our values we
should acknowledge
as you say we absolutely should
acknowledge the advances over
the uh rival moralities of its time
such as child sacrifice or human
sacrifice more generally
uh wow slavery was prevalent throughout
the ancient world still is on the earth
today there are people you know there
are societies that practice slavery at
this moment
uh indeed it's not legal anywhere on
earth which is a massive advance and and
probably inconceivable
around the times of the bible right um
so we should
basically we should not search for
saints
and villains and say you know bible boo
or bible that's where our moral our
morality comes from
neither one of those is defensible it's
let's look at what they were saying
let's give them credit for
advances in in their own era
let's know where we have to go beyond it
in
uh in in moral issues that they
did not reason through very well by the
the uh the light of subsequent
thinking i i heard it said once by some
author
i'd rather have uh one reader a hundred
years from now
than a hundred readers a year from now
basically
prefers longevity and i'm asking you
what would you prefer
you know kind of a single person
discovering the works of steve finker a
thousand years from now or a thousand
people tomorrow you know picking up all
the copies of your books
well i sort of think of it the way i i
think of our genealogical progeny our
genetic descendants
uh which i have zero directly through my
own line although i have some i do have
some nieces and nephews
um but which is that you can't uh
clone yourself it's not you that's going
to be
uh or that ought to be uniquely
remembered
but you're contributing to a collective
body of knowledge
and the uh what i would hope to do is
make contributions that
make the entirety of our knowledge
more accurate deeper uh not that someone
would point to me and say oh he got it
right
however numerous they are now or a
hundred years but that the whole
idea pool has been
enriched some by some increment thanks
to what i've tried to work out
absolutely and it has and we're talking
again stephen pinker johnstone family
professor at
harvard university uh an influence on me
although we
just meeting for the first time i love
your your mind steven
it's it's uh it's so engaging when i
listen to you and i
and i read your works um but just to get
back one last thing on the bible
you know i always say look the bible had
to speak to people thousands of years
ago in a language they could understand
it's not simplistic
people that trivialize it it's just for
bronze age peasants you know
it's it's fairly sophistic
linguistically etc um
and even self-consistent and has
obviously
troubling aspects richard friedman dick
friedman is a good friend of mine
uh formerly here at uc san diego who
wrote the bible his famous work
uh but i always say you know something
like that that spoke to people thousands
of years ago we don't know exactly when
it was
you know in its final form but still
speaks to people it still will
you know not only would i trade you know
my sales of my book you know for one
percent of god's book sales i would i
would kill for one percent
but uh but but also the longevity as you
say and maybe i want to turn to that
because i know you don't have too much
time you're so generous as it is already
but i've heard it said a lot but you
talked about transmission to the future
not for your own progeny i always point
out like uh steve what was the name of
your eighth great grandparent on your
mother's side's first name
like nobody knows what you know who that
is and that's like a couple generations
you know before right um and that means
i think per force that in the future no
one's gonna know who i am i have kids
and
they'll have kids hopefully uh but eight
generations later i don't know who brian
keating was
hope i mean hopefully unless i do
something uh to make note of it but i
want to ask you what
what is sort of the most precious
commodity to you
is it uh you know material immaterial
but um but it's often said well you know
money is very important or time is very
important
what commodity do you think is the most
conserved precious commodity
there is in life well certainly um
love and trust of my family um
and and that time indeed time
opportunity to
uh access to knowledge and and uh
information
um now the material
prosperity enables many other things in
life such as access to knowledge
uh and uh not least time
uh so it would be a little hypocritical
to say that it means nothing
and indeed one of the things that i
learned in documenting human progress
is that prosperity at least at the level
of
nations leads to a lot of other really
good things
richer countries on average are
more literate more peaceable more gender
egalitarian
uh are uh are safer less likely to get
into wars there are so many
notable exceptions like the united
united states but
uh prosperity by itself
should not be a a goal but a lot of
things that prosperity brings
are are also valuable now this is not
doesn't mean
that that's why i want to get as rich as
possible but it does mean
that i do appreciate the living in an
affluent
democracy and all of the gifts that it
brings now we're talking here in april
of 2021 and you know prince philip
of england just died and he died at
almost 100 years old a storied life and
i was thinking when he was born you know
in the in 1921 or whatever
he uh he you know nobody on earth today
would trade
their life and their lifestyle uh for
hit the life of the king or queen of
england at that time in other words
the the lives of people today even the
poorest among you know american society
let's say
are better than the richest kings and
queens of europe of 300 years ago
and so you know that is in part due to
this flourishing of human
of the human spirit and that's why
sometimes it does trouble me steve when
people
uh want to get out of the problem of say
anthropocentric global warming which we
both agree upon
but they want to get out of it by brute
force approach so for example i don't
know if you're familiar with this
it was a great crisis both on wall
street and in london
it was called the great horse manure
crisis of 1894
and it shut down wall street for weeks
and months at a time
because the traders couldn't get to wall
street because the streets were covered
in
horse crop and the same thing was
predicted in the times of london
predicted that by eight 1934 the streets
of london be covered under nine feet of
manure now there are some people say
that wouldn't be
a bad thing for london but nevertheless
of course it didn't happen and and but
if you had tried to solve the problem
using the technology of the day you
would have had horse diapers
you would have put horses on some you
know vegan diet i don't know which
they're already on a vegan diet as far
as i know what do i know about horses
but but the point being if you try to
just brute force out i think you're
denying the scientific i'm not saying
you but
but in general these approaches where we
just want to truncate the problem brute
force it into a solution
by the means of the way that we got into
it i feel like that short
changes and gives short shrift to the
scientific method
and the scientific progress that it will
kind of invalidate it if i just say to
my kids
kids your future is bleak don't think of
any new solutions
you know for example we could have
radioactive non-radio
radioactive thorium is much more clean
source of nuclear fuel
with fewer side effects and fewer
applications for militaristic
uh deployment of that fuel um but we
seem to just want to either shut off
down all
petroleum power or shut down you know
call digging and
and that has improved but what do you
make of this that that
by telling people to curtail something
in science you're
maybe stunting the possible growth that
could get us out of future problems
on earth well i think you know putting
aside the
the the the horseman you're scare and i
think some historians have
to have a kind of jaundice view as to
whether
whether whether there are apocryphal
elements to some of those
fears but nonetheless it is definitely
true that the
approach to climate change that says we
have to reverse
the industrial revolution we've got to
stop economic growth
we've got to moralize so that everyone
massively conserves and goes back to a
simpler lifestyle
is just is just not going to do it it's
not going to solve the climate crisis
because
people want energy they need energy it's
how we got out of extreme poverty
it's how the rest of the world is going
to get out of extreme poverty and
if we tell them stay in your current
level
standard of living they're just not
going to listen to us
likewise any solution that depends
on uh heavy restrictions of
of energy capture is going to
around furious political opposition
which means that our
probably our best hope for getting out
of the climate crisis is to develop
sources of energy that are so
simultaneously abundant and clean and
cheap
that people will just naturally opt for
them and that
once something is invented then uh you
know donald trump can't uninvent it the
way he can pull out of
the paris climate accords or any other
political
solution that we that perhaps a more
enlightened
administration implements a less
enlightened administration after them
can reverse
but not technological advances you can't
uninvent them
so if we did have thorium uh power and
like you i think this
should be explored invested in together
with other sources of abundant
zero carbon energy uh both conventional
nuclear fourth generation nuclear
perhaps even fusion although that you
might have
stronger opinions on that than i do uh
but we should pursue them because that
that that is a
path towards solving the climate crisis
now it might also depend on changing the
incentives i don't i wouldn't say that
it's only technology
that will um lead to a zero carbon
economy it may be that a price on carbon
that
uh increases the incentives to develop
clean energy might be part of the
solution although then
then again uh what we've learned and
i've i'm starting to change my mind on
this that even though
carbon taxes are in some sense the most
rational way to
uh move us in the direction of a
zero-carbon economy
what one would hope people would do when
there's a carbon tax is to
insulate their water heaters and and uh
turn down their thermostats
in fact what they do is they put on
yellow vests and they riot and they set
cars on fire and they block
the subways so again even uh what i
would consider a fairly moderate
political economic solution
immediately runs into problems that a
technological solution does not
uh kind of subject that involve
my more my field obviously i'm not going
to ask you to
come up with a 26 dimensional string
theory but i do see
a very interesting dynamic that is more
or less unknown or unprecedented in my
field
maybe it harkens back to the big bang
versus steady state
debates of the previous century but this
involves theories of everything
and and and so-called quantum gravity
and the unification of forces and fields
with
the unfinished business of einstein and
so we have a book now
uh the god equation michio kakou is on
the show
and uh this this follows up on some of
the work it actually ends with the exact
last lines
of stephen hawking which in his brief
history of time were
if we can come up with the comprehensive
theory of everything then we will truly
know the mind of god
and i wonder you know my your colleagues
and my colleagues you know in the
physics department that study condensed
matter physics and
the properties of a superconductor here
or some you know some
atomic particle they never talk about
these grandiose terms of god the god
particle
the uh the the mind of god the the um
you know so-called the god equation what
is it about
you know physics in particular that
engenders these really kind of violent
you know
uh like flights of grandiosity perhaps
uh
or or is it really you know to be
expected of something that purports to
understand and explain
the origin of the universe and
everything we see around us
it's not entirely a coincidence because
often our
thoughts turn to god when we ponder the
uh
ultimate deepest explanation for the
explanation for the explanation of
everything
and that's that's when people kind of
say oh that's what god's for he's the
answer to the question what's the
ultimate explanation of
everything so they're the physicists
find themselves in the same territory as
the theologians
although so do the psychologists because
together with the
uh you know the cosmological argument
well god is there to press the button
and
he he he presses the on switch for the
universe
uh but of course god is also invoked to
explain
the soul and consciousness and and uh
awareness
and biologists find themselves rubbing
shoulders with theologians because of
the the argument for design was always
one of the most compelling
reasons to believe in god namely how
could something as complex as
the body of an animal arise from
mindless physical laws well there's got
to be a cosmic designer
so i think the three of us the
psychologists the biologists and the
physicists
find ourselves bumping up against
theological questions and at some point
we
especially in physics the um you know
the mind of god
you know if you're a spinoza and here
i'm going to defer to my
my other half rebecca rebecca goldstein
who's uh among other things an expert in
spinoza
spinoza is a version of god he's called
a pantheist
and people assume that he must think
that god is in
uh you know flowers and trees and
bluebirds and babbling brooks but what
he really meant was god is in the
ultimate theory of the final theory of
everything in physics
that god is just a synonym for whatever
equations there are
that explain the universe and themselves
so there is
uh maybe there is a bit of spinozistic
thinking in the physicist invocation
of god to uh as an uh and equating it
with
the you know their ultimate goal and of
course einstein quite explicitly was a
spinozist
right yeah although his divining his uh
ultimate understanding or
reckoning with god is uh is more
complicated coming up with a theory of
everything in some sense
because he said you know it's like they
said of stephen hawking he changed his
mind so much no matter which side
of the bet you took you always won but
just the last thing
on that front uh maybe it's related to
it but i'd be fascinated to hear what
you have to say in your book
um in light but now you talk about uh
things like
beauty and simplicity and elegance and
and you say something like would billy
holiday
and you know would she be appreciated by
some intelligent alien
you know is beauty just you know does an
aardvark you know
find uh miss universe attractive no
there are some things that are you know
context-dependent and there are other
things that might be universal i wonder
do you think
that we would search for things like the
theory of everything
because it's kind of a heuristic it's
like a hack it says it would simplify
things if there was a theory of
everything but i'll point out
you may not know this maybe you do
there's no guarantee that there is a
theory of everything in other words
the theory of everything is needed to
quantize gravity but
gravity in its quantum form is only
relevant in two instances one is at the
beginning of time
if the universe emerged from a
singularity which we don't know and can
never observe
and two at the center of a black hole
within its event horizon which is
fundamentally unobservable
so in other words the two main city you
know reasons for the
for quantum gravity to exist for the
quantization the need for quantum
gravity
are unobservable and therefore we have
no contact with them
um do you think that that this you know
holding up the paparian
and i would love to talk to rebecca i
i'd love to have her on the show to talk
about this but while you're here until
she comes on
we tend to venerate popper as
mathematicians venerate girdle in other
words
the lat we have mathematician envy you
you psychologists talk about penis envy
well they say the biological sciences
have physics envy
uh we have math envy because at least in
mathematics you can prove which is
fundamentally unprovable
but in physics there's no law we just
have heuristics so
what what do you make for advice for a
scientist like me i mean what would you
be guided by is it really the pot
bearing demarcation or is it something
you know
more more profound than that perhaps
well i i tend to in terms of the
philosophy of science or the
capturing the scientific methodology i
tend to think that the bayesian approach
is more convincing than the poparian
approach the pop
the popper might even be a special case
of bass namely that it's not that
uh it's not the skeet shooting model of
science where you throw out a hypothesis
and then
see whether it survives the bullet of
falsification but we increment
our credence and hypothesis up or down
it's not just a binary
falsified not falsified uh evidence can
increase confidence in a hypothesis or
decrease it without falsifying it
altogether
and indeed i i i'm not
enough of a philosopher or science to
work this out but i suspect that a lot
of the
uh the the biases that uh
scientists in general and physicists in
particular have
toward beauty beauty in a theory
an elegance maybe that it's uh it
deserves a kind of
bayesian high prior probability
because it's so uh to the extent that
what we sense as beauty is often
parsimony simplicity elegance that is a
small number of postulates
can uh unfold to deduce a large number
of implications
then you have to believe fewer things a
priori
if you posit an elegant uh beautiful
simple theory than
a complex one you're kind of on the hook
to prove more
if you start out with a more complex
theory than if you start out with a
simpler theory
and maybe there's something to be worked
out there as to why
uh why it it seems reasonable for
physicists to pursue beautiful theories
and why
often though i i i'm sure you can give
me examples that not always
the simple beautiful theory turns out to
be correct but i'm sure they're
conspicuous cases where it has not been
the psychological question is why as you
point out and i'll uh
you're kind of channeling william james
who said to the to the bearers the
she-bear that is meant to be loved to
the lion the lioness
uh our own standards of beauty uh seem
parochial and species specific on the
other hand as david deutsch pointed out
your
fellow physicist is it a little bit
curious that
uh flowers evolved to attract insects
and we find them
beautiful or butterflies
or peacocks since the
peahens sense of beauty and our sense of
beauty
overlap and not because of dissent from
a common ancestor those
evolved independently could there be
some kind of
platonic definition of beauty
that peahens and humans independently
stumbled upon
maybe having to do with some sort of
counter-entropic
force that is or or uh phenomenon
something that gives us pure colors as
opposed to muddy brown that you get from
mixing stuff together
symmetry highly improbable state
arrangement of matter
repetitions simplicity things that
signify some kind of underlying causal
force
amidst the chaos of the universe and
therefore are worthy of attention
regardless of species that's a kind of
speculation at the intersection of
physics and psychology
i really resonate with that figuratively
at least but yeah i want to point out
that
they've done studies and i'm sure you
know this really take you know brad pitt
who with the present exception of you
and you and i
was once voted the most handsome man on
earth and uh they take his face and they
they split it down the middle and they
reflect the left on to the right he's
hideous and he's grotesque so it's
really the broken symmetry
and that applies to physics as well the
higgs mechanism
spontaneous symmetry breaking uh your
shelly glacial
former harvard uh you know disciple of
schwinger etc these are all broken
symmetries and that's where the physics
gets interesting
i want to finish up if you have you have
two more minutes three more minutes
steve yep
okay so you wrote a wonderful book
speaking of parsimony called the sense
of style it's not as well known but
it should be as well known as all your
other books uh and it speaks about this
you know the distillation and the
construction of a voice and a style as a
writer
i want to ask you first of all what's
the best
writing advice you ever heard or gave or
you know received uh and then what book
do you give out
most frequently that's not your own as a
gift
oh yes uh i guess the
two main bits of writing advice would be
to read good writers savor their writing
try to reverse engineer
what makes it work because they're just
too many rules
to memorize them one by one and you're
never really going to assimilate them if
you memorize them and apply them
but if you absorb good writing and you
think oh gee that sentence
really zing so it's really beautiful
what makes it work that's one bit of
advice
another is to be aware of the curse of
knowledge the fact that when you know
something it's extraordinarily difficult
to imagine what it's like
not to know it and probably the chief
sin of writing
especially in the sciences is that when
writers assume too much on the part of
the reader it's just obvious to the
writer at the time
and they don't bother to provide the
vivid
uh perceptual detail the concrete
examples the explanation of the
technical concepts that are second
nature to them
but not to their uh readers
certainly strunk and white uh the
elements of style is the first style
manual i got and it's got a lot of flaws
but it's charming in its own way and a
lot of the bits of advice that it has
after the test of time not all but a lot
of
a lot of especially their prime
directive which is an excellent example
of itself
omit needless words that's right and
superfluous commas that are
extraporaneous no
okay so steve the last section of this
uh of this podcast is called the
impossible three the thrilling three if
you've got a couple more minutes i'll
ask them and we'll get you out of there
so the first one involves writing and
it's writing your ethical will
and it's something that is known in
hebrew as a zava ah and people use it
jews non-jews people with children
without children it's essentially meant
to distill
your wisdom or ethical teachings into
something that your ideological errors
as you spoke about earlier would inherit
not just your biological errors for
those of us that have them
what would you put on a will that would
encapsulate your ethical imperative if
you will
well the original uh ethical will from
jacob to his
uh 12 sons was a little bit problematic
it included you know may you have your
hand around the necks of your enemies
so i think i'll appeal to a slave right
a slightly later era in judaism the
the uh rabbinical as opposed to the
tribal
uh era and i don't think we can do much
better than rabbi hillel who said
if i am not for myself who will be for
me if i am only for myself
what am i and if not now when yeah
well you're the second uh humanist uh to
uh to to quote from the from the bible
the tanakh the other one was a
woman by the name of andrewian who was
carl sagan's uh
widow and she quoted um act justly
love mercy period so she quoted from
mika but the last sentence is walk
humbly with your god but if you admit
she omitted that as a good humanist
would okay second question
what material object or knowledge would
you put on a monolith
like that in 2001 a space odyssey that
has
uh meant to be discovered by
extraterrestrials that basically is a
billboard to say
how awesome was planet earth back in the
in the year 2021
what would you put on a billion year
lasting time capsule
well uh how about the contents of
wikipedia
it would be a pretty pretty big um solid
state
drive but uh but it it should be doable
and it would be hard to single anything
out but it itself
is a remarkable cultural achievement and
of course embedded
in it would be uh the vast amount of uh
of human knowledge that we have
accumulated much better than one of
those aol
cds that we used to get in the mail last
question steve going backwards in time
instead of going billions of years or
hundreds of years the only way
of according to arthur c clarke the
namesake of our
organization here the arthur c clark
center for human imagination the only
way of discovering the limits of the
possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible that's the name of
this podcast origin
i want to ask you as a 20 year old or a
30 year old what advice would you give
yourself to give you the courage to do
as you have done
to go into the impossible well i've i
think
a great part of wisdom is to savor what
you have to appreciate what you have
and uh i have been so improbably
uh fortunate in my life that to look
back with regret would itself be
unwise i i by no means let a perfect
life lots i've
suffered tragedies as all human beings
have but in terms of the
fates of humanity i just have to
appreciate how fantastically fortunate i
am and to look backward in appreciation
rather than
regret her second guessing steve i could
talk to you for hours but you'd grow
weary of me and and maybe get harvard
bodyguards out on it
steven thank you so much for going into
the impossible with me and i wish you a
wonderful weekend
and all the best i hope we can meet
someday in person i sure hope so thanks
so much brian
thanks steve any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
if you like this video please let me
know what you thought in the comments
do you think people are intrinsically
rational or irrational
and if you enjoyed it you'll definitely
want to check out this video i did with
noam chonsky
stephen pinker's crosstown rival at mit
noma is the father of cognitive science
and he's an expert in everything from
aliens to elon musk
you won't want to miss this interview
click here and don't forget to subscribe
and leave
a like thanks a lot